good morning John at your video about
the time when you almost fail to class
and then your teacher made you not do
that reminded me of the time that
exactly that same thing happened to me
which maybe says something we'll get
there and 11th grade I took a landscape
design course so I learned about plants
and how to plant plants and take care of
them and arrange them in people's yards
that class weirdly was at a different
campus so after fifth period I had to
get on a bus and go to a different
school and sometimes I would not do that
instead I would go sleep in the band
room I skipped that class because one I
wasn't taking it very seriously but to
my school had a policy that if you got
more than ten unexplained absences you'd
fail the class but before that nothing
happened so I kept very close track of
my unexplained absences so that I would
have exactly ten of because I was that
kind of self-important egotistical
churned out into the semester it wasn't
more than ten it was ten the teacher
told me that I would be failing the
class and I got really mad and I wasn't
mad at the teacher I was mad at myself
for thinking I could be so clever and
smart and being wrong about that and I
think it helped me realize that I was
just sort of taking it for granted that
I would always be let off but regardless
of any of that I was very pissed off and
I went into the hallway I like walked
out of the classroom and I kicked a
locker door that was hanging open
I was wearing steel-toed Doc Martens
because it was the 90s and a locker door
flew across the hallway like it just
ripped off and flew away and now I'm
thinking okay well I failed a class and
I've destroyed school property so I'm in
much more trouble I go back into the
classroom
everybody's looking at me and the
teacher says out loud I'll mark it down
is not so somehow John I went from
failing a class then I destroyed
property now I'm not failing what
happened here even in that moment it
felt wrong to me I didn't question it
because that would have been a bad day
headed home to tell mom about actually
did a lot of kind of like bad stuff in
high school and I did it knowing that it
was like a risk but it wasn't a big risk
and I remember back then thinking that I
was just good at getting away with stuff
why because
you know I looked like this and I had
good grades and I had so much potential
you know that thing that people say is
that's the thing you were humans we
never stopped doing the math prejudice
and privilege aren't a sign of like some
kind of interior rot they're not a
disease that monsters have their signs
of biases that we all have and deal with
yes sometimes racism is cruel and
violent and intentional but sometimes
racism is just that a white kid looks
different to you kicking the door off a
locker than a black kid does I think a
lot of America's really stuck on this
idea that racism is a secret disease
that only monsters have there's a link
to something that gene Denby wrote that
helped me think a lot more correctly
about this stuff and that says it better
than I could but a thing I've been
thinking about is it seems like the more
you have the more people are wary of
taking things from you and the less you
have or are perceived to have the more
society is okay with exploiting you or
punishing you or just giving up on you I
want a sociologist to explain this to me
but it seems real seems like both a
cause of increasing inequality and the
kind of thing that only gets worse with
increasing inequality and yeah it seems
like it's the source of a lot of bad I'm
really grateful to have been raised by
parents and had mentors and teachers who
helped me realize that I wasn't just
some clever kid who is just so good at
getting away with stuff cuz I still see
people my age thinking they're that
person and it's a bad look but that
instead I just was a person who had a
lot and so people were wary of taking it
away and that among many things is a
good thing to know and there are many
other things that I think I still need
to learn John I'll see you on Tuesday